OK, thank you all for coming today
to our conference entitled
"Rokhl Oyerbakh: The Bridge Between
Wartime and Postwar Testimony." My
name is Stephen Naron and I'm the
director of the Fortunoff Video
Archive for Holocaust Testimonies.
This is the 12th event in the
Fortunoff Archives 2019 event
series marking 40 years of
recording video testimony.
And indeed, about 40 years ago,
on May 2, 1979,
Laurel Vlock and Dori Laub recorded
the first four testimonies that would
establish the Holocaust Survivors Film
Project, the immediate predecessor to
the Yale's Fortunoff Video Archive for
Holocaust Testimonies.
And we are still recording testimony
today.
In fact, a few weeks ago, Joanne Rudof
and Sue Millen recorded a testimony
with a French child survivor at
Yale's broadcast studio.
From its beginning, the Holocaust
Survivors Film Project was built,
funded and staffed by many survivors
as best embodied by William Rosenberg,
a survivor from Czestochowa,
who served as the president of the
project prior to its arrival at Yale.
The first 183 recordings
from the Holocaust Survivors Film
Project came to Yale in 1981
with the help of Geoffrey Hartman.
Professor Geoffrey Hartman, who fled
on a Kindertransport from Frankfurt.
His wife, Renée, was one of the first
four survivors recorded in 1979.
And under Geoffrey's leadership and
Joanne Rudof's stewardship, this
collection grew to encompass more than
4,400 testimonies
of survivors, witnesses and
bystanders. We now have 12,000 hours
of recorded material, in over a dozen
languages, recorded in a dozen
different countries.
I'd like to thank a number of
individuals for making this conference
possible. First, to the speakers who
have come far and wide, from as far as
Israel, Germany and Poland.
A shoynen, shoynen dank.
Thank you for your willingness to
share your scholarship, your
intellectual labor, your dedication
to what Oyerbakh accomplished and
stands for.
My thanks to the Fortunoff Blaustein,
Ross, Libby, and Kohl families
and the many other donors to the
archive for their unflagging support.
I'd like to thank our honorary
advisory board and our Faculty
Advisors Council in particular.
I'd like to thank Sam Moyn, who
gave me the creative spark for
organizing this event series,
it's a year long event series, and who
helped me, together with Sam Kassow,
build an exciting series with
this conference, this Oyerbakh
conference at its heart.
Although there are several more events
in the series, and I encourage you all
to attend, again, I want to emphasize
this really was the beginning
of the entire event series and
marks a sort of climax of this
year long effort.
So thank you, Sams plural.
I'd like to express my gratitude
for the support displayed by Susan
Gibbons, university librarian,
and my supervisor, Christine Weideman,
the director of Manuscripts and
Archives, as well as Maurice Samuels
and Renee Reed at Yale Judaic Studies
Program.
I'd also like to thank Yale's
Program for the Study of Antisemitism,
David Simon at Yale's Genocide Studies
Program, and Doug Rogers at Yale's
Russian, East European, and Eurasian
Studies Program.
Finally, I'd like to thank the
Fortunoff Archive's staff and
postdocs, in particular Debra Bush.
Today would not have been possible
without Debra's incredible
organizational skill,
her patience and in
getting every detail right regarding
travel, logistics and catering, etc.
Debra has worked at Yale for more than
40 years, and
more than two decades at the Fortunoff
Video Archive.
She's our institutional memory and
administrative oracle of Delphi,
and the heart of the archives,
sustaining all aspects of the work
we do.
So please join me in thanking her.
I'm certain that I forgot, I forgot
many other individuals whom I owe
thanks and I hope they will forgive
me for my omissions.
Before I introduce today's keynote
speaker and I'm going to cut my my
presentation short because we're
already running behind,
I just wanted to say a few things
about why the Fortunoff
Archive is organizing a conference
like this today.
I believe that the connection between
Oyerbakh's work and the archive is
self-evident, but that connection
may not be as clear to
the rest of you.
After all, Oyerbakh died in 1976,
three years before the Fortunoff
Archive's predecessor organization
began taping in New Haven.
But as her-- as head of Yad Vashem's
oral testimony section, her work
set a path that we would follow and
expand upon.
Orit Noiman at Yad Vashem was kind
enough to give me a copy of Oyerbakh's
Oral Testimony Guidelines, which is an
18 page Hebrew document which I had
translated.
It was drafted in 1962.
She compiled it as a manual for
the poorly paid staff and you can see
how poorly paid the staff was in the
guidelines that she's telling them not
to, you know, not to give up hope
despite how, how poorly they're
paid, and the teams
of vol-- a team of volunteers
recording testimonies for Yad Vashem.
When I read it, it was no surprise to
me that her motivations for
recording testimony and her
methodology so clearly foreshadowed
the work the Fortunoff Archive would
start in New Haven.
And I quote, "The testimonies
we collect from Holocaust survivors
are one of the most important Jewish
sources to preserve and research a
time of devastation.
These testimonies will help countless
future researchers, teachers,
psychologists, sociologists,
students and ordinary people learn
about the Holocaust from those who
survived it." She continues,
making explicit the connection
between past efforts to do this and
her present work by naming
Emanuel Ringelblum as the first
man, the first man
to perform an organized documentation
work as a way to record the events of
World War II, already
composing the first questionnaires to
collect, preserve and document the
period.
She then turns her attention to
methodology and purpose, and I can't
help but smile when I read her words
as they echo the Fortunoff Archive's
training manual compiled by Joanne
Rudof and Dana Kline, perhaps
two of our, our most
Oyerbakh-ian like figures of the
Fortunoff video archive.
And I'll quote again from
Oyerbakh's manual.
"We must allow the witness to speak
freely and we must follow the thread
as naturally as possible.
Otherwise we risk losing some of the
trust we built.
We must not forget that this testimony
is in fact an autobiography and
it's first and foremost the witnesses
story."
And so with that,
that's an end quote.
And now I, it's my pleasure to
introduce our keynote speaker, Sam
Kassow.
Sam is the Charles Northam Professor
of History at Trinity College.
He's the author of several works,
monographs and innumerable
articles. His most recent book
was the edited volume called "Listen
and Believe: the Ghetto Reportage of
Peretz Opoczynski and Jozeph
Zelkowicz" from Yale University
Press in 2015 and
his critically acclaimed work, "Who
Will Write Our History?
Emanuel Ringelblum and the Oyneg
Shabes Archive" from Indiana
University Press.
That book has been translated into
eight languages?
Eight languages.
It received the 2007 Orbis
Prize and was a finalist for the 2008
National Jewish Book Award.
Sam has been a visiting scholar at
Princeton, at JTS, Wesleyan,
many, many others,
and has received a list of
scholarships and fellowships, far too
numerous to name.
Beyond his scholarship, he has made
numerous significant contributions to
the field in other capacities.
In particular, one highlight would be
his work developing a section of
the modern exhibit at
Poland Museum in Warsaw
and his contribution
to Roberta Grossman's cinematic
translation of his own book "Who Will
Write Our History?" which, if you have
not seen that film, it is fantastic
and I believe will be screened at the
YIVO gala in a few weeks.
He has also served appointment, in
appointments, official appointments
for the Association of Jewish Studies
and is on the board of the Center for
Jewish History and many, many
other contributions.
Finally, Sam has always been an
incredible supporter of the Fortunoff
Video Archive and this support,
I think, is both intellectual and
personal.
He's a member of our honorary advisory
board, a lifetime appointment honoring
his enormous scholarly achievements,
but also his deep personal connection.
After all, he is a New Havener Yid,
and he spent much of his childhood
among the survivors in New Haven, and
his mother gave testimony to the
Fortunoff Archive twice, once
in 1980 and once in '87.
In fact, her testimony will be
featured as an episode in the
Fortunoff Archive's new podcast
series, "Those Who Were There," to
which Sam is also contributing
by composing a series of essays for
each episode that provide historical
background and context.
Sam, the Archive is grateful for your
guidance and support, the generosity
with which you've advised me since
I've returned to Yale to take this
position and your assistance
with arranging today's conference.
Please join me in welcoming Sam.
Thanks a lot, and
it's a, it's a great honor
to speak
at this conference
in,
on the legacy of Rachel
Oyerbakh,
a woman who,
while she lived, got much
less recognition and
praise than she deserved.
And, of course, many thanks to the
Fortunoff Video Archive,
to, to Stephen Naron, Debra
Bush, to Yale University, to
Professor Samuel Moyn
for making this conference possible.
Today, we will hear from many scholars
who, representing different
disciplines, have all
done much to help us
better understand
her rich and multifaceted
legacy.
Her life was linked
to such diverse topics
as women in Jewish culture,
regionalism and folklore.
Her key role in
the Galician journal "Tsushtayer,"
and the Landkentenisher movement.
Her life was linked to pre-war Warsaw
as a Yiddish cultural center.
Of course, the Oyneg Shabes archive
in the Warsaw Ghetto,
the Central Jewish Historical
Commission in postwar
Poland, her involvement
in films such as "Unsere Kinder,"
which we saw last night, her
very fraught career at Yad
Vashem, the Eichmann
trial where she did yeoman
work behind the scenes to
bring survivor testimony into the
courtroom.
What Annette Wieviorka called
"the era of the witness"
came about in no small
measure, thanks to the
unstinting efforts of people
like Rokhl Oyerbakh,
their efforts to highlight
the importance of survivor testimony,
the Eichmann trial being a key
example.
At a time when scholars like Raul
Hilberg argued that documents were
better sources than survivor
accounts, Oyerbakh countered,
yes, documents are well and good,
but they were a source that usually
had more to say about perpetrators
than about victims.
And long before the work of,
long before the recent synthetic
history of Saul Friedländer
or the work of Jan Tomasz Gross,
Oyerbakh insisted
that the voice of the victims be heard
in a way that scholars
and jurists take survivor
testimony seriously,
focusing not just on content
but also on the nuances of body
language, phrasing,
affect, language
itself.
And so what if those
giving testimony got some
dates and names wrong?
Their authority of witness
far outweighed mistakes
in the details.
Oyerbakh began listening to the
victims as early as
1941 in
a soup kitchen in the Warsaw ghetto.
As early as 1942,
as she wrote down the testimony
of Avrom Krzepicki, an
escapee from Treblinka.
She did this for the Oyneg Shabes
archive, an encounter that changed
her life as one of only
three survivors of the Oyneg Shabes
arcive, Rokhl
Oyerbakh had the opportunity
not only to retrieve her wartime
writings, but to rewrite
and publish them
in such books as "B'hutsot
varshe," "Varshever tsavoes,"
and "Baym letsten veg." And
there were significant differences
between what she wrote during the war
and how she rewrote those same pages
later.
As she handed over her first
cache of ghetto writings
to the Oyneg Shabes on
July 26, 1942,
in the middle of the chaos
and horror of the deportations
to Treblinka.
She attached a note that
exposed her feelings.
Raw fear, violent
anger, despair.
And now I'm quoting: "I'm
handing over this unfinished essay
to the archive, the fifth
day of the Aktion.
Perhaps such horrors have already
occurred in Jewish history,
but such shame never.
Jews as tools of the killers.
I want to stay alive.
I'm ready to kiss the boots
of the worst scoundrel
just to be able to see the moment
of revenge, revenge,
revenge.
Remember."
In that same note, she wondered
whether her writings would share the
same fate as the scribblings
of a coal miner trapped in an
accident with no survivors
whose body would never be found.
Would anyone read those notes or
anyone care?
And besides, she could no longer write
coherently.
And if she survived, what good
would she be to anybody?
Fast forward two years
to early 1944.
She was now on the Aryan side with
false papers.
She no longer had any doubts.
She had to write.
This was a debt she owed to the dead.
But at the same time, she had to be
careful.
The mass murder, the murder of
millions of Jews by the Germans
is a fact that speaks for itself.
It's very dangerous to add to this
subject interpretations
or analyses.
Anything that is said can quickly
turn into hopeless hysteria
or endless sobs.
So one must approach the subject
with the greatest caution in a
restrained and factual manner.
This has been my intention.
Not to express, but
to transmit to
note only facts but not
to interpret.
But she quickly added that she
realized immediately
that this mandate was impossible
even for herself.
After the war in Poland
and in Israel.
After she'd recovered her wartime
manuscripts, her writing would take
on yet another purpose to
ensure that the Jewish people
remember.
Not only to keep faith with
the dead, but also to use
the lessons of the Holocaust
to strengthen the nation and
tighten the bonds between Israel and
the diaspora.
Oyerbakh left Poland for Israel
in 1950, and
while she had many difficulties in
her new home, she never wavered
in her conviction that after
the Holocaust, Israel had become
the vital center of the Jewish
people.
And for those who read Yiddish,
I highly recommend her book "In
Land Yisroel," a book
of reportage from the early 1950s
that revealed the devotion to the new
state, as well as her
empathy for the struggles of the new
immigrants, the Jews from the Middle
East and North Africa,
no less than survivors of the
Holocaust, although her comparisons
of certain Yemenite Jews to Jewish
villagers in rural Galicia
might be something of a stretch.
Like all good reportage,
Oyerbakh's postwar books
conveyed what she saw
and observed in evocative,
powerful language that
made her writings an indispensable
source for the cultural
and social history of
the Warsaw ghetto.
For Oyerbakh,
memory and mourning demanded
a painful return
to the intense, vibrant world
of pre-war Jewish Warsaw,
which one of her mentors,
the Yiddish poet Melekh Ravitch,
had called a sprawling mosaic
of different Jewish worlds,
different tribes and subcultures.
Chasidim Polish-speaking
professionals, Litvaks.
Oyerbakh took the shattered
bits and shards of that world
and reconstructed a mosaic of memory
based on a poignant evocation
of dozens of individual vignettes.
And thus she spoke for those who
have no one to remember them,
the ordinary Jews she came to
know in the ghetto as she ran
the soup kitchen on Leszno 40
and the Jewish writers, artists and
actors whose milieu
she shared in the 1930s
and in the war.
The more one knew about what
and whom the Germans had murdered,
the more one could grasp the enormity
of the national horror, the national
catastrophe.
As Oyerbakh struggled to describe
the destruction of Warsaw Jewry,
her story elided into a
plaidoyer for Warsaw's particular
place in the history
of the Polish Jews.
In 1945, Oyerbakh
recalled that she
had first come to Warsaw exactly
20 years before,
during the intermediate days of
Passover 1925,
just as tens of thousands
of Jews were streaming to the Gensha
cemetery to dedicate
the Peretz mausoleum, the Oyhel
Perets, which miraculously
survived the war.
And now I'm reading Anita Norich's
translation.
"But that was the first time I'd seen
such a thing.
And I was astonished and deeply moved.
Organized and spontaneous delegations
swept through the masses of Jews
of all walks of life, wearing
caps and hats and yarmulkes,
businessmen and workers, young
and old, a mobile force
of people.
To my eyes that look like something
out of Asia.
I could never have seen such a thing
among Jews in Lwow.
This was Jewish Warsaw.
And this was how it expressed its
feelings for one of its spiritual
leaders, as many Jews
as were then gathered in the Gensha
cemetery are not now
to be found in all of Poland.
Around that same time after the war,
the writer Leo Finkelsteiner, a friend
of Oyerbakh's, wrote in the dos
amolike Yidishe Varshe
that Warsaw's strength
derived not from
zkhus oves, but from
zkhus otzma, not from its historical
tradition but from a sheer mass
in power.
Warsaw had no encrusted traditions
and thus could serve as a path breaker
in the modernization of Jewish life.
What Finkelstein thought of Warsaw
when Finkelstein thought of Warsaw,
what he emphasized like Oyerbakh,
were the crowds, the masses
of Jews who came to Peretz's funeral.
To the May Day demonstrations to
see the Hasidic rabbis.
By the same token, in a postwar
essay comparing Vilna and Warsaw,
the literary critic Shlomo Beilis
wrote, Is it not symbolic
Warsaw struggled?
He refers to the ghetto uprising.
Wilna furnished the song, the
partizan song, although
at a critical moment, the Wilna jews
rejected armed rebellion.
Is this not a reflection of
the entire history of these two great
Jewish centers?
Warsaw earned its place
in East European Jewish history
because of its quantity,
as well as its quality.
Because of its enormous Jewish
population, she took first
place in the Jewish world.
Abraham Lewin, a key member
of the Oyneg Shabes, wrote in late
1942 that
Warsaw was the nerve center of
Polish jewery and Polish
jewery was the cultural center
of the Jewish people.
So how could the Jewish people
survive this massacre
that Lewin, who would soon be murdered
probably in Treblinka, could
ask this question, only
underscores the special agony
felt by Holocaust victims
who, before they died,
had to witness the destruction
of their families, the
destruction of their people, of their
language without any
trace of consolation,
such as the knowledge, for instance,
that a Jewish state would arise after
the war.
If Oyerbakh could do nothing else,
she could at least ensure
that posterity remembered
what this great Jewish metropolis
had meant.
Before the war, Oyerbakh
herself admitted to a certain
ambivalence about Jewish Warsaw.
On the one hand, she fiercely
defended the Jewish masses
against articles
such as a demeaning reportage
Charlie Long, The
Dark Continent, which appeared in
an elite literary journal, Wiadomosci
Literackie, which compared
the Jews of Warsaw to
the denizens of
Africa and saw
them as interesting specimens
worth of anthropological study
but little more.
Oyerbakh went ballistic, and
she accused the author Wanda Melcer
and by extension, the entire
Wiadomosci Literackie
milieu with its heavy representation
of brilliant intellectuals of Jewish
origin, of pretentious arrogance
and ignorance.
Yet on the other hand,
Oyerbakh freely admitted
that before the war, she herself
had shared some of the widespread
pessimism about the future
of Warsaw as a Jewish and
more specifically, a Yiddish cultural
center.
She expressed real doubts about the
cultural future of Yiddish,
especially in light of rampant
acculturation and the economic
woes of Polish Jewry.
But after the war, she revised
her previous skepticism.
It would be easy to dismiss
Oyerbakh's change of heart
as a post-Holocaust need
to sanctify what had been destroyed.
But that would not be accurate.
Like her mentor Ringelblum,
writing in late 1943
and '44, Oyerbakh
devoted a large part of her
wartime and postwar writings
to the Warsaw Jewish
intelligentsia.
Writers like Kalman Lis
and Joseph Kirman, Yisorael Shtern.
Actresses like Miriam Orleska.
Painters and sculptors like Avrom
Ostrzego and Roman Kramsztyk.
Composers and choir
directors such as David Eisenstadt.
She described Shie Broyde,
her boss in the Aleynhilf,
who had translated Plato's dialogs
into Yiddish and who, had
he only survived, would have enriched
the Yiddish language beyond compare.
If only this play
had survived, if only
that cantata, if only
that poem.
What she heard in the ghetto, she
wrote, represented a flowering
of Jewish genius, a
bright flame just before the final
destruction.
In her postwar writings,
Oyerbakh openly explained
that she had doubted the prospects
for Yiddish culture in Poland
because she had underestimated
the vitality of the Polish-Jewish
masses.
It was her work in the Aleynhilf, in
the self-help, in the soup kitchens
when she came into close contact,
not just with ordinary Jews,
but with the impressive leaders of
the religious world
that she never would have come to know
had it not been for the war.
It was then she began
to understand, according to her
writings, that Jewish
life was so deeply rooted,
the Jews were so numerous
that the nation could have counted on
the capital, the cultural capital
of Polish Jewry, for generations to
come.
And now, I quote,
"Despite everything,
we were surrounded with enormously
powerful and dynamic Jewish folk
masses, too
numerous and too rooted
in their culture for acculturation
to threaten the basic character of the
nation.
The religious strata were an
enormous reservoir of human
resources and spiritual
energy, and they would have made
up any losses that we were suffering
towards Polish culture.
We thought that we had arrived in
Jewish Warsaw too late.
We thought we'd arrived after the best
was already over.
In fact, the blooms faded
only to prepare for the next harvest
of fruit, and
this would have happened had it not
been for the terrible catastrophe that
befell us."
As soon as the war ended,
Oyerbakh resolve to carry
on Ringelblum's legacy
and to find the tin boxes and
milk cans buried under the trackless
rubble of what had been the Warsaw
ghetto.
The Yiddish writer Mendel Mann
recalled Oyerbakh's talk,
the third anniversary commemoration
of the ghetto uprising.
After many tiresome speeches
full of political posturing,
Oyerbakh, the only woman on the
podium, got up to speak.
She didn't make any speeches.
She didn't explain the meaning of the
uprising with a stubbornness
that deeply affected me, she demanded.
She called. Remember, she cried out.
There is a national treasure under
the ruins.
Even if there are five stories of
ruins, we have to find the archive.
I'm not making this up.
I know what I'm talking about.
This isn't just talk.
This is coming from my heart.
I will not rest and I will not let you
rest. We must rescue the Ringelblum
archive.
Now, many people were skeptical.
They had their own troubles.
They didn't need the archive to tell
them what they'd been through.
But Oyerbakh disagreed.
Now, more than ever, survivors
had to organize.
A systematic and collective
effort to record the past and
to continue the work of the Oyneg
Shabes.
The traditions of the Ringelblum
archive could counteract disturbing
trends that she had already
noticed in early postwar
memoirs. For example,
the eminent, the memoirs of the
eminent biologist Ludwig Hirschfeld,
a convert to Catholicism,
or the pianist Wladyslaw
Szpilman, according
to her, presented a skewed
and distorted picture of the ghetto.
But what could one expect, she asked,
from individuals who had been so
distant from Jewish society before
the war.
On the other hand, Oyerbakh also
attacked the memoirs and writings
of many nationally conscious
Jewish survivors for their tendency
to settle political scores
and nurture ideological jealousies.
And this was always a pet peeve
Oyerbakh's. And again, she held up the
model of the Oyneg Shabes,
where she believed a shared
sense of national mission had
trumped political differences.
In the aftermath of a catastrophe,
a wounded nation had to look at its
record, the good as well as the bad
to tell the whole truth, to add
and subtract nothing.
This was a debt owed not just to the
victims who had died,
but to the nation that had to recover
and rebuild.
Oyerbakh hallowed the exploits
of the ghetto fighters and the
partisans.
But she did not want their story to
overshadow and diminish
the memory of the 99 percent
who had no weapons.
Like much of the Oyneg Shabes staff,
Oyerbakh was close to the circles
of the pre-war YIVO, the
Yiddish scientific institute, with
its traditions of breaking down
barriers between scholars and ordinary
Jews, of zamling,
a mass movement to collect documents
and source materials.
A key goal of the YIVO
was to explore the everyday,
so derkenen dem haynt, to
understand day, daily life,
to explore this through surveys,
interviews, to encourage
personal documents such as
autobiographies.
And I highly recommend
Oyerbakh's review of Shie Perle's Yidn
fun a gants yor, Ordinary Jews,
which appeared in Literarishe bleter
before the war, which really shows
Oyerbakh's closeness to the
ethos of the YIVO.
Indeed, the very structure of
Oyerbakh's wartime writings
emphasized the close links
of the Jewish intelligentsia and the
masses.
The first title of her essays on
the murdered writers, musicians and
artists was "Tsuzamen mitn
folk," "Together With the People."
Oyerbakh's work followed in the
footsteps not only of the Emanuel
Ringelblum, but also of YIVO
director Max Weinreich,
who made special efforts to
incorporate the insights
of Sigmund Freud and of social
psychology into the study
of Polish Jewry.
In the highly politicized and
divided world of interwar Jewish
Poland, where so many stressed
the primacy of the collective over the
individual, Weinreich,
in his youth studies, yugnt
forshn project, for instance,
argued that one
could not understand Klal
Yisroel, the collective,
without grasping
the needs of Reb Yisroel,
the individual.
The aspirations, drives, obsessions,
hopes of the many individuals
who made up Polish Jewry,
Oyerbakh, whose main field of
university study had
been psychology and who had written
extensively on the field in
the pre-war Jewish press, needed
little convincing.
And so, too, in her Holocaust
writings, she highlighted,
she highlighted the complex
interplay of psychological
factors in individuals,
families, entire social groups.
She told a complicated story
resilience, vitality,
self-sacrifice, on the one hand,
corruption and moral collapse
on the other.
She also had brilliant insights,
the result of conversations with
folklorist Shmuel Lehman in the ghetto
about how rumors, jokes,
street songs could
be seen as a self-defense reflex,
a poignant but powerful
sign of the instinctive resistance
of the Jewish masses.
Oyerbakh stressed the German's
skillful use of psychological
weaponry to effect
the destruction of Warsaw
Jewry and to use the
Jews' strengths against
them.
The Germans played with the Jews
and with their natural human
instincts of self-preservation
and hope.
In her brilliant observations
of the mass hysteria that gripped
the Warsaw ghetto in the summer
of 1942
to get into a shop, to bribe
people to get a work certificate,
Oyerbakh described how the
very qualities that
had served Jews so well in the past --
practicality, pragmatism,
hard headedness, "seykhel,"
and natural optimism --
now accelerated their journey
into the abyss.
And now I quote" "and still
other Jews broad-shouldered,
deep voiced with powerful
hands and hearts.
Artisans, workers, wagon drivers,
porters, Jews who with the blow
of their fists could floor any
hooligan who dared entered their
neighborhoods.
Where were you?" This is Leonard
Wolf's translation, by the way.
"Where were you when your
wives and children, when your
fathers and mothers were taken
away?
What happened to make you run off like
cattle stampeded by fire?
Was there no one to give you some
purpose in the confusion?
You were swept away by the flood
together with those who were weak
and you sly, cunning merchants,
philanthropists in your short fur
coats and hats.
How was it that you didn't catch
on to the murderous swindle?"
Now, would other peoples confronted
with the similar massive assault,
have acted better?
She did not think so.
Did Warsaw Jewry eventually recover
from the shock and fight back?
Yes.
Should one blame the Jewish masses
for not having fought back earlier?
Only those who had not been there,
Oyerbakh implied, would do so.
Was armed resistance the only
way that you stood up
to the Germans?
Absolutely not.
Oyerbakh was a superb observer
of the Jewish everyday.
As I said, she had a fine sense
of the nuances of
the behavior and speech of different
classes of Polish Jews,
whether they lived in small towns
or in urban centers like Warsaw.
Like Ringelblum, she was a native
of southeast Galicia.
Before moving with her family to
Lwow, she spent her childhood in
a remote village, not a shtetl
in Podolia, Lanowitz,
where she acquired a love of Jewish
folklore and the Yiddish language.
The great Jewish folklorist and
ethnographer Shmuel Lehman had
interviewed her many times
about the folk songs and customs
of the rural Podolian Jews.
Like many other Galician Jews,
Oyerbakh combined this deep
Jewish identity with the first
class Polish education cultural
sensibility at Lwow
University in the early 1920s,
Oyerbakh befriended the young
poetist Debora Vogel and
the budding writer and painter Bruno
Schulz, and she urged both
to start writing in Yiddish
and Vogel indeed did so.
In 1929, she helped begin
Tsushtayer a literary journal
that tried to bring the
Polish-speaking Galician Jewish
intelligentsia closer to Yiddish.
Oyerbakh would go on to have many
interests, but one of the most salient
was her devotion from the very young
age to get her secular
culture.
Her vision of that culture was
inclusive rather than exclusive,
one that united rather than divided.
That transcended political
differences, a culture whose
creativity would shame those who
regarded Yiddish as nothing more
than a low class jargon.
But in the end, Tsushtayer
was a bridge too far.
It folded in 1932 after
three issues, unable
to overcome financial difficulties
and disagreements over politics.
For Oyerbakh, Yiddish culture came
first, politics second.
But others disagreed.
And one more thing.
As she started the journal,
she had to endure some condescending
and misogynistic sniping
aimed at her and at Dvora Vogel.
This might have been the first such
incident in her life, but it was
definitely not the last.
In the late 1930s in Warsaw,
she earned the nickname "di
literarishe baylage,"
"the literary supplement,"
a snide reference to her relationship
with Itzik Manger.
And later on, she would wonder
if her path in Yad Vashem
would have been easier had
she not been a woman.
But that only encouraged Oyerbakh
to redouble her efforts to
highlight the critical contributions
of women to Yiddish literature.
Despite her love of Galicia
and of Lwow
she realized the Yiddish high
culture faced a bleak future there.
In the 1930s, she moved, in 1932,
she moved to Warsaw.
After her brief marriage to the poet
Ber Schnapper failed, she became
the companion of the brilliant
and tempestuous Yiddish poet
Itzik Manger, and supported
herself precari-- precariously
by translation and by writing
articles and reviews for the
Jewish press in Polish and Yiddish.
Much of the power of Oyerbakh's
reportage stem from her ability
to navigate cultural boundaries
derived from a life that straddled
many different worlds village,
shtetl, and city.
Yiddish and Polish, Poles and Jews.
Galicia and Warsaw, the milieu
of the Jewish literary elite
and the world of the Jewish masses.
Religious and secular.
Diaspora nationalists and Zionists,
she straddled them all.
At the end of September 1939
after Poland's capitulation,
Oyerbakh was about to flee to Lwow
when she received an unexpected
summons from Emmanuel Ringelblum
to stay in Warsaw and run a soup
kitchen. Again, I'm basing this on
what she wrote.
Most of the Jewish elite had
run away from Warsaw, but Rinelblum
had reminded Oyerbakh that
not everyone had the right to run.
Ringelblum thus brought Oyerbakh into
the far flung network of the
self-help, the Aleynhilf
of the Warsaw Ghetto.
With its hundreds of house committees,
dozens of soup kitchens, day care
centers and
refugee shelters,
the leaders of the Aleynhilf saw the
organization as the conscience
of Warsaw Jewry, a counterweight
to the Judenrat.
During World War One, the Yiddish
writer Yitzhak Leybush Peretz
had stressed the interdependence
of relief and zamling,
the recording of history and
in the Second World War.
By the same token, the Aleynhilf
made the functioning of the Oyneg
Shabes archive possible.
Ringelblum used the soup kitchens and
refugee centers to gather information,
to camouflage the gathering of
information and to find writers.
And at the same time, by giving
them jobs, he tried to save the
cadres of the Jewish intelligentsia.
In 1941, he
recruited Oyerbakh to the Oyneg Shabes
by asking her to write about the soup
kitchen. And Oyerbakh would stress
that had it not been for Ringelblum,
she would not have written anything.
Oyerbakh's Soup Kitchen on Leszno
40, which fed 2000
Jews a day,
offered her a unique vantage
point to get to know and
observe a large number of,
quote unquote, customers.
The story that Oyerbakh told
provided a gripping behind the
scenes look at the desperate
battle that the ghetto was waging
against hunger.
Oyerbakh investigated
the social history of hunger
by telling the story of a soup kitchen
as a microcosm of human relationships
and human choices.
The dead who ended up in the pits of
the Gensha cemetery, were
not an undifferentiated mass,
but individuals whose idiosyncrasies
Oyerbakh recorded.
She deftly caught the phrases
or the habits that made these
individuals memorable.
The young mother expelled
from her shtetl, who arrived
at the soup kitchen with four children
in tow and a tot
suckling at her breast, a
family of solid, rugged Jewish
boys from a country farm
who had just been expelled.
And each day they take a bowl of
soup for their aged father.
And whenever they mentioned him, they
never failed to add "biz hundert un
tsvantsig," "may he live to 120."
Many solid members
of the Jewish middle class now
reduced to desperate poverty.
Oyerbakh, as the director
of the soup kitchen, confronted
serious psychological pressures
and moral challenges.
Like other figures of the Aleynhilf,
she had seen herself
as an honest public servant
imbued with the moral code
of the progressive Jewish
intelligentsia.
But very quickly, she discovered that
for the masses of starving, desperate
people who came to the kitchen each
day, she represented authority
and power.
In their eyes, she had become an
arbiter of life and death.
Like Ringelblum, she had
come from a militia that was
imbued with love for, quote unquote,
the Jewish masses.
But now these masses, those
ordinary Jews, stormed her office,
blocked her in the corridors and
begged for extra soup tickets.
They looked at Oyerbakh as someone who
could save them.
Some confronted her in silent
supplication.
Others yelled and loudly
reminded her of their former status.
Then there were the children who would
come in packs and cajole
her in Yiddish accented Polish
prosze pani, prosze, pani for
some extra food.
And it seemed to her then,
as if the kitchen only prolonged
the agony but really saved no
one. Should she favor a chosen
few or dole out
equal rations and save no one?
Ringelblum asked the same question.
Increasingly frustrated,
Oyerbakh singled out a chosen
few for special care.
The religious poet Israel Shtern,
for instance, or a German
speaking refugee from the
Sudetenland who had survived Dachau
and whom Ringelblum wanted to keep
alive as a witness.
This former athlete,
the Daytsch, as he was called in
Warsaw Yiddish, won Oyerbakh
over with his impeccable
manners, his good nature,
his spry sense of humor.
For Oyerbakh, Brockmeyer
became a litmus test and a challenge
she bent her rules and gave him extra
food. When he began to become
apathetic, a common sign of
starvation, she would yell at
him that she could feed him, but
that he had to summon up the will to
live. It was important Oyerbakh,
though, to win at least one
victory.
But here, too, she failed.
In her diary entry of
August 4th, 1941, she
noted that "what is the use
of all our work if we can't save
even one person from death
by hunger?" Ringelblum
soon gave her new assignments.
In September 1942,
he and Shmuel Winter asked Oyerbakh
to interview Avrom Krzepicki, who
just escaped from Treblinka.
And there was a protocol of more than
100 pages written by Oyerbakh.
Krzepicki did not survive,
but after the war, Oyerbakh developed
a special bond with the Treblinka
survivors, about whom she
wrote in the late 1940s
and whose honor she defended in the
1960s during the controversy
over Steiner's book.
In February 1943, she
escaped to the Aryan side
and helped by Polish friends,
she procured Ayran documents
and became a courier for the Jewish
underground.
On the Aryan side, after
the ghetto uprising, Oyerbakh
wrote a constant stream of essays for
what she called arkhiv hemshekh,
the continuation archive.
With the help of Polish friends,
Oyerbakh buried her writings in two
different locations in Warsaw
on the grounds of the zoo and
then a field in the southern district
of Mokotow.
Both caches survived the war.
As Oyerbakh wrote, "I had better luck
in saving paper than
in saving people."
One of the greatest of her wartime
works, one of the very few translated
into English, was "Yizkor,"
first written, she said,
in late 1943.
And we'll hear more about this from
David Roskies.
Sitting on a Warsaw trolley car,
she'd seen a Polish woman weeping
over her son, who the Germans
had shot, and Oyerbakh realized
that she didn't have
the luxury of openly mourning.
And so she went back to her apartment,
so she wrote, and began
her great elegy for Warsaw Jewry.
"Yizkor, I may neither groan
nor weep. I may not draw attention
to myself in the street and I need to
groan. I need to weep.
Not four times a year.
I feel the need to say Yizkor four
times a day.".
Yizkor is the service of remembrance,
a prayer of remembrance.
She poured out her soul
as she tried to describe the murder
of Warsaw Jewry.
The toddlers, the children who she
remembered from the ghetto schools,
the tough Jewish workers, the hardened
women shopkeepers, young scouts,
courting couples, intellectuals
all gone.
Even if a few individuals survived,
the vibrant, raucous and diverse
mosaic of Warsaw Jewry had been
destroyed.
"Yizkor" humanized the victims
by recalling not only their
individuality but also their
city, the specific urban
milieu that had shaped them and
that had made them Varshever.
In another essay she wrote,
Oyerbakh indeed regretted the lack
of armed resistance until January
1943.
But "Yizkor" was different.
Unlike the works of some other Oyneg
Shabes writers who observe the
deportation like Yoshue
Perle, Israel Liechtenstein
or Perez Opocynski, Oyerbakh's
"Yizkor" was suffused with empathy
towards Jews rather than anger,
as David Roskies has pointed out,
by using the imagery of a flood,
of a natural disaster at the beginning
of "Yizkor." She anticipated
future questions that those
who were not there would pose.
No, the mass murder was not a
meta-historical event, but
its enormity was too horrible
and to unprecedented to allow
for glib theories and facile questions
that might compromise the memory
of the ordinary Jews she cherished
so deeply.
And how does one resist the
flood or an earthquake?
What befell the Jewish masses was
so unthinkable and so calamitous
that they were psychologically
unprepared.
Implicitly, Oyerbakh was anticipating
the invidious distinctions that many
would make after the war between
the few who fought back with weapons
and the masses that allegedly died
without a fight.
It was the people she wrote about in
"Yizkor," not the fighters who'd
written up, who'd risen up just months
before.
And in the end, a secular writer could
only repeat the words of the
traditional Yizkor prayer.
For Oyerbakh, Yizkor
was a return not to religion,
but to the murdered world of her
birth, to a folk community
that did not have to invent new words
to describe pain and loss.
They were already there in the
prayers.
Like her murdered friends, Oyerbakh
was "tsuzamen mitn folk,"
together with the people.
One of the more striking
features of Oyerbakh's writings
of this period is her portrayal
of Poland and the Poles.
As a courier who distributed money
and aid to hidden Jews, Oyerbakh
was in constant contact with
the category very small
in number, of Poles
who most Jews during the war never had
a chance to meet the liberal
intellectual elite.
Her descriptions of such individuals
as Jan Zabinski and his wife
are particularly instructive and
insightful.
Zabinski had been the director of the
Warsaw Zoo, as well
as an officer in the Polish
underground.
During the war, he and his wife had
helped many Jews, including Oyerbakh
herself.
Her intense devotion to the memory
of Jewish Warsaw in no way
diminished her deep empathy for
Polish Warsaw and its sufferings.
In Varshever Tsavoes,
she painted a sympathetic portrait
of Warsaw's Mayor Stefan Starzynski,
who called out his fellow citizens to
resist the Germans and
who led the city during the days of
the terrible siege in September 1939.
Right after a terrible bombardment
of Jewish neighborhoods,
Starzynski paid a visit
and stroked the heads of Jewish
children.
Perhaps, Oyerbakh speculated
as he walked through those Jewish
streets, Starzynski was thinking
how, before the war, Poland
had treated its Jews as second class
citizens.
At least that's what she wrote.
Perhaps the terror of the siege had
one silver lining.
For a brief moment, the fight against
the common German enemy brought
Poles and Jews together and offered
another glimpse into the heart of what
might have been.
Before the war, Starzynski
had, to put it mildly,
he'd not been known as a philosemite.
But like so many others, Oyerbakh
speculated, perhaps the war
caused him to grow beyond himself.
Many people,
Oyerbakh noted, would
wonder why
Starzynski and his fellow Poles
defended Warsaw in September 1939.
It was such a hopeless fight that led
to so many needless civilian
casualties.
Another Warsaw Jewish diarist, Chaim
Kaplan, had nothing but contempt
for a doomed battle that caused
so much suffering.
But Oyerbakh, nurtured on
Polish romanticism, was full of
admiration and I quote,
" Romanticism, idealism.
Let the naysayers get the contempt
they deserve.
Other Europeans peoples
did not fight.
But we Polish Jews understand
what the Poles did.
We were at their side and
we understand today."
Now, Oyerbakh's relationship to
Poland was paradoxical
and complicated.
And hopefully we will hear more about
the subject later on, especially from
Karolina.
Oyerbakh the Yiddishist actually
did most of her wartime writing in
Polish and in her
book of reportage, In Land Yisorel,
she spoke about Jews leaving
Poland after the
war for Israel, carrying
Jastrun's biography of Adam
Mickiewicz.
And in that same book she
wrote about the final days before
she left Poland forever
to go to Israel.
And she remembered that
when her grandparents had left Galicia
before World War One, they
had spent months going
from shtetl to shtetl,
saying goodbye to multiple relatives.
Now she was leaving Poland and
she didn't have one relative to say
goodbye to. She'd lost everyone.
But whom did she visit?
She spent those final days
with the Polish family who
had been her childhood neighbors
when she'd lived in Lanovtsy as a
young girl and who, after the
war, had moved
to the former German territories
in the West.
Her description of that visit,
that kind of,
end of of a chapter
in her life
underscored the close bonds
that she felt had existed between
Poles and Jews in that distant
rural past.
And of course, Oyerbakh was no fool.
During the time she was in Poland,
about 1500 Jews were murdered
by, by Poles.
And I'm not saying
her attitude towards Poland was one of
unalloyed admiration,
but there was certainly an element of
paradox here.
In the tension between her wartime
writings and
her postwar emendations.
One can discern a marked shift
not just in subject matter, but in
emphasis and attitude.
In her wartime writings and reportage
for the archive, Oyerbakh
judged herself harshly.
The soup kitchen had been a failure.
The Aleynhilf, an exercise in
futility.
But after the war, she realized
the kitchens had been more effective
than she thought,
and that Polish Yiddish culture, as
I said, had a future.
The same pattern of self-criticism,
followed by positive reevaluation,
emerged in other postwar writings.
After the war, she joined the Central
Jewish Historical Commission in
Poland, where Philip
Friedman, Joseph Kermisz, Michal
Borwicz and others were busily
documenting the Holocaust and
publishing the first serious studies.
At the time, she focused on the
defects, rather the achievements of
the, of the historical commission.
But,
and she thought
that they were falling short,
but in Israel in the 1950s,
she changed her tune.
Compared to the paltry record of
scholarship on the Holocaust in Israel
and elsewhere in the 1950s.
She now wrote that postwar Poland
had been a golden age of Holocaust
research.
In Israel at Yad Vashem, her single
minded determination to foreground
Holocaust research and the collection
of survivor testimony caused
major conflicts, which Boaz Cohen
will talk about.
It is sad but true that her last
years in Israel were not happy ones.
Oyerbakh, to put it mildly, was not an
easy person to get along with.
And I sense that in her last years
she felt a great deal of bitterness
and frustration.
And so to return to what I said
earlier, in conclusion, we
are not only here to talk about
an important woman, but
we're also here to right a wrong.
And I would like to end this talk by
quoting something of Peretz's that
Oyerbakh repeated in 1945.
When surveying the rubble of Warsaw,
she thought back to the legacy
of this great tribune of modern
Yiddishkeit, who had once sought
to inspire a new
Jewish culture in Poland,
in Eastern Europe, anchored
in both Jewish tradition and European
humanism.
And I use Anita Norich's translation
from her book, Discovering Exile.
"Console My People.
It needs consolation, strengthen
its heart, shore up its spirit.
Don't be the wind that puts out the
flame.
Instead, pour oil and tend
the wick because night is poison
and despair.
Death, console my people.
It needs consolation."
Thank you.